[Musique]
oui mais venant parole aux actes
antisémites sa mort du cuir aujourd'hui
bien sûr je veux faire un retour sur la
première journée nationale de vérité
réconciliation une journée fériée au
fédéral mais pas du tout français quand
on parle du québec
pourquoi est ce que je vais faire un
retour là-dessus sic c'est de se rendre
compte que c'était plus important qu'on
le pensait c'est pas une journée
nationale
comme pour se rappeler des souvenirs
historiques
je pense je parle beaucoup souvent des
par exemple des patriotes au québec ou
même la journée du souvenir
jeudi soir on fait des retours dans les
médias sur le 11 septembre qui s'est
passé aux états unis parce qu'on a
besoin de se souvenir de se rappeler des
fois même de passer à travers des
moments difficiles en tant que nation en
groupe il a pu imaginer que quand on
parle de survivants des pensionnats
c'est des gens qui sont encore en vie
aujourd'hui qui subissent encore
aujourd'hui des impacts que leur passage
dans les pensionnats a eu sur 1 on parle
aussi des enfants de céder ses
pensionnaires des gens qui ont été aux
écoles de jour et on oublie aussi on
veut faire le deuil des milliers
d'enfants qui sauront jamais retournés
chez eux deux ces pensionnats l'enquêté
de disposer des lieux d'éducation et qui
on le sait aujourd'hui
par le pas sont des lieux qui était
synonyme d'abus d'expériences
scientifiques
de coupure avec la relation familiale et
la relation culturelle donc oui cette
journée là était très important
on vivait des choses émotionnellement
des choses nationalement aussi mais
la personne qui j'aimerais vraiment
mettre une place d'honneur dans ma
chronique c'est monsieur françois
legault qui a eu un rôle quand même
assez triste septième puisque
plutôt que d'être un leader dans dans la
réconciliation québec entre les
communautés autochtones et allochtones
s'est positionné d'une façon assez
maladroite mais aussi assez dangereuse
pour certaines communautés on a vu
certains de ces commentaires par exemple
autour de
l'invitation de monsieur bruno dubois 1
reconnaître racisme systémique et dans
sa posture et dans ses mots y est traité
quand même les personnes qui veulent
faire reconnaître le mot racisme
systémique de radicaux
c'est quoi quel genre de radicalisme
utile pour les communes de taille comme
de vouloir faire reconnaître
deux mots collés ensemble qui ont un
impact et nos coûts de gens mangeront
mais c'est juste des mots pourquoi est
ce qu'on pense pas par dessus ça parce
que les mots ont une importance cruciale
que ce soit en droit que ce soit dans
les lois les mots sont débattus dans les
cours les courses breham donc les mots
ont une importance et qu'on fait des
mots on fait des lois autour de ces
moules ont fait des processus autour de
ces moules et ceux qui s'obstinent
contre ces mots là nous disent aussi que
non une nouvelle pas avoir à gérer
l'impact émotionnel de ces moules donc
ça a commencé avec ce la semaine de
réconciliation pour moi il fallait
continuer avec beaucoup d'autres
approches qui était très dangereuse et
2d celles qui m'ont plus marqué c'est de
dire on veut que les québécois sont
fiers on veut pas faire sentir mal les
québécois les québécois les québécois je
sais mais je peux sans c'est moins de
compter comme une québécoise je peux
sensible d'être compris dans la vision
du premier ministre comme une citoyenne
québécoise alors que quand je l'écoutais
je voyais vraiment qu'il voulait opposé
l'histoire des premières nations à
celles des québécois est donc à la
vision que les québécois avaient deux
mains et ça si c'est pas le premier
ministre du québec qui crée un système à
deux vitesses
citoyenneté québécoise qu'est ce que
c'est parce qu'en plus dans sa
description de du racisme systémique de
ses systèmes s'est soudain monsieur le
premier ministre vous êtes celui qui est
en haut vous êtes celui qu'avait d'un
pouvoir et quand il dit les démarches
qui le fait pour que la situation comme
celle que joyce et chaque fois n'avait
il ne se reproduise plus
c'est vraiment dur mais vous mettez en
place des solutions contre le racisme
systémique mais je mens jamais ne
voulant jamais le nommer donc vous faire
comprendre que pour moi il ya un bris de
confiance face au premier ministre du
québec est censé ne représentait même si
dans sa tête je fais partie du fédéral
la loi sur les indiens je suis participe
quand même en tant que citoyenne
québécoise au même titre beaucoup
d'autres québécois et met à cet aspect
là je deviens dans son système de
réflexion un membre à part donc il crée
lui-même dans son esprit pour défendre
justement contre les enjeux qui nous
touche compte des enjeux qui sont
reconnus par les institutions même qui
était problématique compte qui reconnut
le racisme systémique est même reconnue
par des grands leaders de pays tels que
les états unis et utilise souvent le
modèle américain pour le comparer mais
même aux etats-unis ils reconnaissent
que le système le racisme est systémique
existe donc je me sens très peu en
confiance et par le fait même ça me dit
que les personnes qui envoient pour nous
discuter des enjeux qui sont important à
nos yeux
vaut dépendre de la vision que ce
premier ministre de ce qui est des
enjeux de qui ça touche et quand il me
parle j'ai touché par le racisme
systémique il ne parle pas des premières
nations ne parle pas des communautés
autochtones il me parle de l'identité
des québécois mais pas tous les
québécois
donc vous comprendrez que c'est des
enjeux super difficile et que le fait
que les gens le répète le disent et ils
veulent au s'obstiner mais veut y
compris justement une vision qui est
arrêté dans un débat qui devrait aller
de l'avant je vois pas ça comme
une forme de radicalisme je vois ça
comme des gens qui veulent même
s'assurer que on soit pas laissée
derrière dans la mentalité de nos
leaders alors n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer des questions parce que je suis
sûr que ça va en créer énormément
cette discussion là est pour aller de
l'avant continuellement parce qu'il va y
avoir d'autres enjeux et surtout si on
refuse de reconnaître le racisme est
systémique si on refuse de se mettre au
travail pour le transformer le
transformer le système il vient enlever
le racisme est bête ce sera plus un
système qui doit être pour tous avec un
système à deux vitesses alors je t'aime
deux semaines j'espère que vous avez eu
une très belle semaine de réconciliation
et que on va pouvoir célébrer autre
chose que les dix ans des enjeux de
productivité l'année prochaine alors
bonne journée